y decenas de jóvenes se enfrentaron a
vehículos blindados de la policía en
belfast mientras los choques entre
manifestantes y autoridades se
prolongaron una vez más durante la noche
del jueves previamente el gobierno de
irlanda del norte con un ejecutivo
compartido por unionistas y republicanos
había hecho un llamado a la calma pero
sus esfuerzos fueron en vano no puede
haber un lugar en nuestra sociedad para
la violencia o la amenaza de violencia y
esto debe detenerse snow drive extiendió
está bien es peligroso es inaceptable y
es un milagro que mientras estemos aquí
nadie haya muerto en aspen girls
los oficiales utilizaron cañones de agua
para dispersar a la multitud que arrojó
bombas de gasolina y misiles en el lado
mayoritariamente nacionalista de la
ciudad mientras intentaban avanzar hacia
el llamado muro de la paz que separaba
el vecindario de shen yun road un área
predominantemente legalista que ha
estado en el centro de los
enfrentamientos en los últimos días
reviviendo décadas de violencia sectaria
los disturbios provienen principalmente
de comunidades sindicalistas ya que los
manifestantes acusaron a las autoridades
de doble moral por no enjuiciar a los
líderes del partido sinn fein que
infringieron las reglas destinadas a
frenar el avance del
19 para asistir al funeral de un ex jefe
de inteligencia del ir a los políticos y
los lugareños también culpan al acuerdo
del brics y tensiones
londres y bruselas acordaron una
frontera en el mar de irlanda en lugar
de una terrestre en la isla de irlanda
lo que provocó una sensación de traición
entre los unionistas